[موسيقى]
وما يميز مدفع قيصر سهوله الاستخدام
واحتياجاته اللوجستيه قليله كما انه سهل
التحريك والنقل ولديه قدره على اطلاق
طلقات متعدده في الدقيقه الواحده والتموضع
في دقيقه ومغادره المكان في دقيقه وهي
طريقه جيده لتجنب المواجهات مع العدو وهذا
ما يجعل قيصر مدفعا حديثا جدا وناجحا جدا
للاستخدام في ساحات المعارك
مدافع قيصر موجوده في المنطقه وكما تعلمون
فان واحده من الدول الكبرى في المنطقه
اشترت بالفعل عددا لا باس به من مدافع
قيصر ووصلنا رد فعل ايجابي منهم عن
استخدامه وكفاءته كما ان القوات الفرنسيه
لديها اتفاقيات دفاعيه مع عدد من دول
المنطقه وهي تستخدم القيصر في تعاون
العسكري
[موسيقى]
ونحن في نكستر نقدم خدمات الدعم لعملائنا
وبالنسبه للمنطقه فان جميع عملائنا هنا
يحاولون تلبيه احتياجاتهم الجديده ونحن
كشركه تجاريه نحاول ان نقدم لهم افضل ما
لدينا من تكنولوجيا لتلبيه احتياجات هؤلاء
العملاء
[موسيقى]
كما تعلمون فان نكستري هي شركه دفاعيه
فرنسيه من الاكبر في فرنسا واوروبا في
مجال تصميمي وتطوير وتصنيع معدات الدفاع
البري
[موسيقى]